this is important because you know this
is what
no other show will talk about but it has
to be talked about
are we reacting with data and facts and
reality
to the police problem or are we just
reacting no i so i think that's a
false question so are we reacting to
data the data shows that
in the past year 1010 people as of today
have been killed by law enforcement
we know that black people in this
country are two times more likely to be
killed by law enforcement
than their white colleagues right but
there is also the factor of
how many interactions with black people
that's called poor policing i mean
what that what that's called that's
called prime disparities that's called
when black people account for 50 of
murder victims and perpetrators
and are overrepresented in contact with
the police you have to take that into
account
you also take into account over policing
of those communities as well
you also take
say they do not want the police defunded
many say they want
as many or more police well let's that
so
defunding the police just so we can be
clear since we're what the world is
watching us does not mean that when i
call 911 or my mom calls 9-1-1 the
police will not show up
but what it does mean is that we won't
have bloated police budgets but instead
we'll have after-school centers
instead we'll have mental health
professionals who arrive on the scene
instead we will actually be able to
build community that's what that means i
think
but i want to get back to you but you
can hardly agree on that i think we need
less policing of petty drug crime
correct um
look at that we gotta look at that we're
making progress right but but
but more policing of you know homicide
and violent crime in neighborhoods where
over half of crimes or
violent crimes are not getting solved so
it's a complex to me
just people have this idea that i want
to see the police budget cut by half
i want to i want to see the police
improve whatever that means for the
budget that might mean
spending more to train them more and so
on and so on but i think we agree
because
not fully but i i don't want i just
don't want less police i just want
better police
right okay so that and that's the that's
the issue we're real
because you know i worry that there's
going to be more riots and more unrest
in the streets and
and over something that may not be true
now charles barkley and shaquille o'neal
commented about brianna taylor yesterday
they got a world of [ __ ] about it today
um
and i think what they were saying is we
don't know if this is a racist
cop killing or just plainly it's
horrible policy
no knock entries yeah finally anyone's
going to get killed in that
situation i agree and i think we don't
we don't need to have
we don't we we don't need to have no
knock warrants we don't need to have
choke holds we need to ban those across
the board i think democrats and
republicans alike
if you want to if you want to take from
tonight's show a policy initiative
it's that however it's not the fact
of the killing of brianna taylor per se
it's the fact that there was a lack of
accountability
that is the biggest issue it's the lack
but because
and malcolm x said it best i didn't
think i would be quoting malcolm x on
bill maher tonight but malcolm x always
talked about the fact that the most
disrespected person
on the planet is the black woman period
and
we see that day in and day out but it's
the lack of accountability you cannot
tell me
that if that was a white woman who was
asleep the police came in her house
fired 20 shots that there would be no
accountability
no indictments for the murder of that
woman so five years ago a man named a
white man named derrick cruz in a very
similar situation
no knock warrant they shot him in the
face completely unarmed
what that tells me is there is a much
deeper issue than racism there's a
reflexive urge to go to the race issue
i understand it but the truth is that
police in general
generally do not get punished for
misbehavior
i mean very rare and it's white it's
black well so
we have to solve that issue of course
but reflexively making it about race
and and this is they were there they're
cops doing a cop
job with a cop handbook and cop training
i feel like that's like the biggest
problem here
cops you know i mean you've talked about
this a lot i mean you have said
racist cops killing unarmed blacks is a
false premise
because if you look at again the data uh
it's like if you threaten cops in any
way
they will kill you that's the problem is
that they're a little and look
they have a very difficult job this is a
country full of things full of nuts
let's be honest no i i agree i agree
with you but if you threaten them
if you resist if you do they think that
that that allows them to just neutralize
the threat
i.e [ __ ] kill you and that's why they
empty like the whole clip into they got
to stop
doing that emptying the whole clip when
they feel threatened
they're i just i i'm not sure that it's
a race thing
i fundamentally believe though that you
see more de-escalation
that you see more individuals who are
able to go home
dylan ruth killed nine people in a
church including one of my friends
right he killed nine people drove all
the way
to north carolina and got burger king
right he happened to make it to prison
alive
and and and the the most recent case
with cal rittenhouse
white boy crosses lines with the ar15
kills two protesters
walks directly by the police with his
hands up and they just say come on back
come on come on by
and so you see he's not represented
though right you're you're
cherry-picking examples
they're they're planted did they not
happen but
i mean the truth is that no you're
cherry-picking them they happen
but for every example you could come up
with i can come up with examples of
white people getting killed in precisely
the same circumstances
that black people do either reaching for
a gun or seeming to reach for a gun
and if we're talking about what violent
crimes go unpunished actually
the bigger problem is that black murders
go unsolved
more often than than white murders do
right so it's not that
the police are are just ignoring
white violence or violence committed by
white people right if anything they need
to be paying more attention
to violence that is committed and
suffered by black people i think that
i think that the point that i'm
attempting to make is not
necessarily that interaction although i
think that's a big issue one of the
larger points is the lack of
accountability
and so when and when a law enforcement
officer however when a law
when a law enforcement officer goes in
and and
just as you said empties a clip or they
we all admit that
law enforcement officers have very
difficult jobs right they keep our
community safe they have very very
difficult jobs
i am just saying though when you
absolutely do not need to kill somebody
or shoot somebody seven times in the
back or whatever it may be
just be held accountable of course of
course
and you know things have changed in that
area but i remember doing
editorials on this show about you have
to hold cops accountable for this
and it's it did happen the last five
years a lot of them who did those
horrendous things like shooting someone
in the back were held accountable but
brianna taylor doesn't even get justice
very different scenario because the cop
was fired upon first
right obviously kenneth walker had every
right to fire because he thought they
were intruders
totally understandable however once the
cop is fired upon
he has to have a right to fire back
there's also a level and i don't want to
be i don't name his murder but
it doesn't it but yes because if you
walk in and you do not announce yourself
right horrible it's the policy right
wouldn't you say that's what i i am just
like i get it yes
i okay but let me just can i say this i
think the system actually worked
perfectly
i honestly do because i don't think the
system is built
for people of color it's not built for
black folk to have accountability
and it's just not the system worked the
way it was supposed to what we have to
do is either
tear the system down or reform it and
reimagine what law enforcement should
look like
you